so how about we talk about the cyber
attack on the United States Fox 5
Washington DC reporting t-mobile Sprint
AT&T and Verizon customers report
widespread cell service outages so I was
sitting in my living room watching what
movie were we watching drop dead Fred
yeah it just I just came on I don't I
didn't pick it it just was like an
autoplay or whatever it's a proof that
that were being hacked yes yeah the
movies bad I haven't seen it in 30 years
I haven't seen that anyway my phone
wasn't working huh yeah and I was like
whoa what is this and then apparently
there's this massive cellular outage and
people started tweeting like crazy about
it but it's not just that there's an
outage and we'll read the story to try
and get down to the facts what's really
going on but it's it's this story check
this out
this person tweeted I have no idea this
person is but they're getting decent
minor retweets this popped up on my
timeline and they say yo that DDoS
attack was absolutely wild this was from
like 15 minutes ago and that wasn't even
the peak so you can you can see right
now for those for those that are
listening I'll describe it you can see
that all of these it's a global map no
big and a whole bunch of like lines are
shooting out of different cities around
the world and just slamming the United
States now I got to be honest this is
eye candy this doesn't really explain
anything about what's going on
Indian yeah so these things whenever
whenever these things pop up everyone's
like whoa look at this cyber attack and
it's like well well well hold on it may
just be someone isolating general
internet traffic and it makes me you
know from like what the US is receiving
or it's requests to the US and so people
will say like it looks like a DDoS
attack it could be it could be a lot of
people think it is there was a tweet
that went out from anonymous they say
the US hit by major DDoS attack on June
15th however it looks like this is not
correct so my understanding is that what
anonymous tweet your non-central tweeted
out they say the u.s. is currently under
a major DDoS attack those aren't
familiar means distributed denial of
service attack and apparently this map
is not current I don't know what I can
say is t-mobile went down and apparently
what happened on is
because one network went down it
affected every network cuz they're
connected okay so I don't know exactly
in what way it affected them I think it
may be as simple as like if I tried
calling someone as t-mobile or texting
them it didn't work and then I would
report issues on my end when it wasn't
okay but also when people's phone
stopped working then they would try and
go on Facebook or Twitter whatever and
then they would go on websites and be
like yo Twitter is down it's not working
it's like they couldn't figure out
what's going on now I do find that weird
that people work this is what people are
saying but but here's what happened to
me I couldn't make texts or phone calls
but I was getting data hmm some things
were working perfectly and some things
weren't well were you connected to the
Wi-Fi oh no of course not
okay yeah that was that was the issue my
itch my phone showed me that cell went
down but the data stayed interesting
yeah and so I couldn't make phone calls
but I could go to websites that's weird
so I wonder if that has something to do
with it I honestly don't know but let's
let's read this and see exactly what's
is all about and then I will explain to
you guys with the DDoS is they say
according to down detector customers
from across the u.s. or reporting
problems with their service with a large
number of reports coming from major
cities including Tampa Miami Atlanta New
York Chicago Houston in LA hundreds of
comments on the website said customers
could not place or receive calls users
flooded t-mobile's Twitter account to
report issues with their service
apparently someone from t-mobile said
our engineers are working to resolve a
voice and data issue that has been
affecting customers around the country
we're sorry for the inconvenience and
hope to have this fixed shortly
a spokesperson for Verizon said down
detector is falsely reporting Verizon
network issues and the company was aware
that another carrier is having issues
but comments from customers and down
detector suggest that Verizon customers
from LA Denver Philadelphia Chicago and
other cities were experiencing issues
placing or receiving calls but the Rison
spokesperson said perceived
interruptions to its service could be
explained by the issues affecting other
carriers a lot of factors can contribute
to a false report on a third-party
website the faulty device network
traffic that slows but doesn't inhibit
connections commercial RF blockers human
error network issues impacting other
carriers and more I got a call
shenanigans on that right now
yeah I'm not buying it now if somebody
has a Verizon phone and they can't make
any phone calls
I'm not buying their excuse well it
could be an RF blocker what that's
illegal are you joking like someone's
running a jammer
on all of these people's phones really
China pull up a truck and like turn on
the cellphone off button get out of here
some-something's crazy going on Sprint
which recently merged at t-mobile also
appeared to be impacted according to
customers on down detector US Cellular
which apparently still exists no I know
that I don't I do appear to be impacted
as well both companies did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment so that's just the story man now
whether or not this is a real DDoS
attack I don't know but people are
pointing out that they're seeing massive
outages across the board on down
detector you know what I kind of I'm
kind of leaning towards I think it might
be an attack yeah I mean we've we've
spoken about it's like where are we
weakest it's not our army it's not our
Navy
it's our infrastructure like our cyber
infrastructure granted this is like you
know phone carriers but no nobody's just
the beginning check this out this suite
here it's not just phone carriers really
that's why I'm saying I think it's
Michael so down detector is showing that
Walmart Google simple mobile fortnight
got hit cricket got hit Airbnb meant
tracfone do you know why I think this is
more likely to be an attack on some kind
of infrastructure so what some people
are saying is just the beginning well
here's here's what I here's the
experiencer that I've seen from people
they said if t-mobile goes down and
you're trying to use your phone and go
to Facebook and Facebook won't load
you'll incorrectly think it's Facebook
right except if your phone doesn't work
and you can't get online you can't go to
down detector comm to tell them right
that's a good point so some people that
was my question but you were like people
were tweeting that it wasn't working I'm
like how are they exactly where's their
Wi-Fi at their house but it could be
that make sense be fair and I still
don't buy this excuse that people
because Facebook saw spike - I don't
think Twitter saw spikes that makes
sense right it could be that people's
phone didn't work so they went on their
computers and then took to Twitter maybe
yeah but I don't see Twitter on this
list so maybe Twitter was down I don't
have that pulled up but everything you
know seems to have some kind of
disruption
I heard discord had a
a blip too although I don't have any
proof of it but people were were
mentioning it in the comments so to
explain to all of you what a DDoS attack
is it's very very simple all you do is
watch the episode of The Simpsons where
mr. burns goes to the doctor and the
doctor has the oversized novelty germs
and tries jamming him through the door
and I mean this literally so he
basically just explains to mr. burns
that he's got every disease known to man
and and this door is the gateway to his
body and because all the germs are
trying to get through at the exact same
time they get stuck so a DDoS
distributed denial-of-service basically
is basically this so you get a bunch of
different computers all at the same time
to make a request on one server and the
server overloads and can't handle it all
so it's basically blocking the door all
those germs being smashed in and nobody
can get in or out
so some people in the past you to liken
it to like a digital sit-in except it's
actually a cyber attack because what you
got to realize it doesn't leave
permanent damage though as soon as they
stop the requests the server will clear
and then be able to answer you know
calls but if a country like China or
some adversary starts targeting our I
don't know say financial infrastructure
you know targeting or power
infrastructure well pop you power is a
direct physical attack right so if they
if they target electricity and shut it
down like that's an that's that's a
physical attack against us you know if
they jam up phone carriers I see they
slowed our economy down right and that
that is a more subversive tactic so it's
actually smarter I think the reason I
lean towards probably some kind of
attack because it happen all the time
all right
and how often happen I mean there's do
attacks literally every day okay yeah
there some maps you can watch online
where it's like here's one here's one
and there's you know assumed intrusions
and stuff like that yeah
but we're probably getting hit by some
kind of attack every single day yeah and
we got to remember nobody's working
still it's not like everyone's gone back
to work excuse me two and a half mil out
of the 40 million that have been out of
jobs it's like people are still like
sitting there on their phones all
day long like well you know hey what
this blip like how long did it last you
know it's obviously the phones are
working now yeah you back was it a
little bit of a blip I don't know is it
a normal thing that happens often and we
don't notice because no today's okay so
I was finishing up stuff in here at like
4:00 for 10:00 and I looked at my phone
and I had zero for this hours yeah I was
hours I was like four hours that's so
long that's a long time yeah yeah man so
that now this feels like a test I had
not seen that yet feels like stage one
let's let's see thanks so much we could
not think that if this was an attack it
was a mistake it was an accident hmm so
if they're actually going to try to
attack us they don't want us to notice
think about all of the business phone
calls that didn't go through because of
this shutdown yeah good point now
imagine if they could shut us down
without us realizing we're being jammed
up they could slow the economy down
allowing them to grow faster than us
build faster than us and that's like you
know it's basically an academic race
we're trying to expand faster than they
are once we realize we're under attack
we show up our defenses and then we take
away their ability to hurt us or they
have to try and invest in new ways to
come after us I think we should do that
anyway yeah for sure
what are we waiting for this is the
smartest thing that whoever it may be
I think everyone's gonna lean towards
China yeah so what would be to a team
like 50 China comments yeah for sure
yeah China hey man they got 1.3 billion
people we got three hundred million
people they got a billion more people
than we do huh yeah I'm not confident
bro I think through CDs trap I mean so
we've talked about through CDs trap
before for those that aren't familiar it
basically means that in the past 500
years there have been 16 times when a
dominant power was surpassed by a rising
power in 12 of those 16 times war broke
out so a lot of people are saying we
have a greater than chance probability
that there will be a war between the US
and China I am NOT confident that we
will come out on the right side of that
one that we will we will survive it I
don't think so with people with China
you mean yeah and I think it might not I
think it might just be a complete
collapse on the USA's end what people
got to realize that they have been
following the stuff China has been
getting its tendrils everywhere and
everything in Australia in Africa and
South America
they were proposing building a
Nicaraguan canal so big to bypass the
Panama Canal think about how crazy that
is
the panic of Panama Canal is a crazy
project to bridge the oceans to get you
through you know through Panama
you know nicaragua's way way more
landmass and that China actually was
like we'll do it we'll get people to dig
a canal through it eventually it fell
through
but they're doing tons of stuff in tons
of country countries Mike Pompeo said
we've already been infiltrated across
the board he said you know he gave a
speech I said all the governors it's
affected you already from every level of
government we've been infiltrated if
that's the case how do we survive this
this is a tweet from Donovan Hale
someone tweeted on my page
excuse me and it's it fits perfect into
this I'm just gonna read it here it says
hi Adam I'm a listener from Anna fan
from South Africa I'm terribly concerned
that you Americans don't seem to realize
that you're the only ones preventing the
CCP from taking over the entire planet I
don't want to be drought it into a war
against the country I wish to move to so
I guess he wants to move to America so
please do whatever is possible to stop
these hippies in Seattle you have no
idea how vulnerable you guys look right
now so obviously it's more than just
this Chas thing and it isn't just
America that's crumpling we got Britain
that's fighting each other France and
France there's a war going on right now
it's like yep it's not just us and then
you probably think what's going on in
China they locked everyone in they've
got everyone in a stranglehold and now
here we're fighting each other and it's
like uses exactly where they want us
look at what was going on in the United
States for the past several decades with
our politicians selling out to China at
every opportunity every our university
professors taking money and then lying
about it and getting arrested for it
yeah they just found like what 14 more
like two days exactly they don't know
every day there are these professors
that are getting paid by China working
at our universities for what does it
call like a thousand talents program or
something no I'm not
yeah I forget what it's called then that
they get grant money from the US so the
u.s. gives them money says do
search then they go to China and China's
like we'll give you some money too why
give you more money but but so some
people argue it's espionage but they're
not charged that they're not being
charged that they're being charged with
fraud because they're lying to the US
government I have I have one idea and
it's it's from my experience working at
these one of these lefty ultra wolken
news outlets okay these companies don't
force you to write woke trash they hire
people who they expect to write write
woke trash and pay them a ton of money
well it's more correctly write stuff
that's gonna get clicks which right
happens to be woke trash because you got
won't go on both sides like I've see
people posting like retweeting and posts
and stuff that's hilarious and cringy
they're like look how bad this is look
how crazy this is and it's getting
retweets and and sending it around well
so both sides here's my point the point
is no one is forcing these people at Vox
or BuzzFeed to write this garbage okay
they just don't hire the people who
would write real journalism they hire
the people who write garbage yeah so
some I'm wondering if the reason these
professors are getting paid by China is
simply because they have subversive or
ridiculous ideas so you think about this
way let's save a really really good
professor is really smart okay teaches
all these young people how to be strong
and good citizens to help save the world
but they don't make a lot of money so
what China does is they find the really
really bad professors and make sure they
live like kings so that they're
empowered to keep doing what they do an
awful job now I'm not saying I know
anything but these professors I don't
know if they're doing an awful job but
they're certainly lying about it yeah
but think about it this way if you have
ten professors five are really good and
five are really bad and you make sure
like they're all underpaid then the five
really bad ones you secretly pay so they
get good health care they have really
comfortable houses and great food they
will thrive and their bad job will will
show in the kids they teach meanwhile
the good professors are like I lost my
apartment man I've got to go somewhere
else I got to move or I can't I can't do
extra activities with the kids cuz you
know I need to moonlight into their job
or something and then you got half of
those who are just getting cancelled for
like trying to stand up for the freedom
of speech just
Yan speak their minds now everybody's
getting cancelled man everybody so you
know a lot of people have been sending
that URI was it your Reba's menagh is
that it the KGB guy oh yeah from the and
I mean yeah it's it's interesting stuff
it's not like a book the actual year
yeah right right just letting everyone
know it definitely seems like some seeds
potentially were planted a long time ago
and they've started to take hold and
there's nothing we can do about it
literally nothing by the time you
realize that your country has been
subverted you have too many people who
believe in the fairy tale and what can
you do about it especially a
constitutional republic like ours think
about all of these people let's let's
say it turns out we actually do discover
then in the nineteen you know 70's or
whatever russia the USSR started funding
subversive programs to spread insane
ideas that they knew would take root in
the next generation okay you have an
entire generation of people whose
worldview is built on this insanity and
even if we knew it was true they would
say I don't care I believe it's true you
can't change them and so now the United
States and the verge of fighting itself
that's one way to get rid of superpower
hey you want to avoid avoid World War
may this is why so many politicians of
the past several decades sold us out to
China they were like me you know it's
easier to just lay down and take the
cash otherwise war would suck right we
might die it makes me what make me
wonder about the past several decades
hmm all of our jobs moving to China the
TPP the trans-pacific partnership Trump
crushed it yeah would have allowed
companies to move freely to China and
send all their products right back to us
and empowering them to control our
medicine all of our manufacturing
basically no it empowered right it did
right what are the TPP right they have
that the TPP would have been tenfold
worse yeah and it was crushed by Trump
Bernie wanted to crush it - thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you